en un vídeo anterior vimos que un cable
recto por el que fluye una corriente
eléctrica produce un campo magnético en
círculos concéntricos a su alrededor en
este vídeo vamos a ver cómo recordar la
dirección del campo magnético producido
por la corriente digamos que esta pluma
representa el cable recto que lleva una
corriente eléctrica y digamos que la
corriente fluye en esta dirección hacia
la punta de la pluma sabemos que el
campo magnético va a girar alrededor del
cable en círculos voy a usar esta
pulsera para representar el campo
magnético su dirección puede ir en este
sentido el campo magnético va hacia la
derecha como pueden ver con la marca de
la flecha o en este otro sentido donde
el campo magnético va hacia la izquierda
así que como recordamos cuál va a ser la
dirección del campo magnético esta es la
pregunta una sencilla regla que todos
usan es la regla de la mano derecha y
dice que tomemos el cable sujetándolo
con la mano derecha no la mano izquierda
sino con la mano derecha
tal forma que el pulgar represente la
dirección de la corriente eléctrica
aquí la corriente eléctrica va en esta
dirección por lo que mi pulgar tiene que
apuntar a esa dirección después los
cuatro dedos que rodean al cable nos van
a indicar la dirección del campo
magnético noten que los dedos que rodean
al cable me dicen que el campo magnético
por arriba del cable va hacia la derecha
por lo que ahora sé que el campo
magnético tiene que ir en esta dirección
por arriba va hacia la derecha
y si la corriente eléctrica fluye en el
otro sentido es decir hacia abajo ahora
voy a sujetar al mismo conductor con mi
mano derecha de esta forma porque el
pulgar tiene que apuntar hacia la
dirección de la corriente de esta forma
ahora fíjense en los cuatro dedos los
cuatro dedos me dicen que el campo
magnético por arriba va hacia la
izquierda lo ven se mueve hacia la
izquierda así que ahora el campo
magnético va a ir en esta dirección a
veces tienen que determinar la dirección
del campo magnético en un punto
específico alrededor del conductor por
ejemplo de nuevo digamos que tenemos una
corriente en este cable que va en esta
dirección y les pregunto cuál es la
dirección del campo magnético en un
punto específico que está aquí a la
derecha del conductor como lo calculamos
bueno de nuevo el primer paso es el
mismo usa en la mano derecha para
sujetarlo por completo y la dirección
del campo magnético será esta que es a
la derecha en la parte de arriba
voy a usar de nuevo la pulsera de esta
forma y una vez que tengan la línea del
campo magnético para encontrar la
dirección del campo magnético en un
punto específico se dibuja una tangente
a la línea del campo así que quiero
saber cuál es la dirección del campo
magnético en este punto de acá del lado
derecho
voy a sujetar la pulsera así quiero
saber cuál es la dirección del campo
magnético en este punto por lo que
tenemos que imaginar una recta tangente
a este círculo en este punto como se
verá voy a inclinar la un poco para que
puedan verla mejor si dibujamos una
tangente acá ésta puede tener dos
direcciones una hacia allá y la otra
hacia acá pero como ya sabemos que la
dirección del campo magnético va así la
tangente tiene que ir hacia abajo por lo
que el campo magnético a la derecha del
conductor va a ir hacia abajo de esta
forma
aquí también puedo rotar la pulsera y
noten que al llegar a este punto espero
que puedan ver que aquí la flecha apunta
hacia abajo cual creen que sea la
dirección del campo
ético por abajo pueden tratar de
encontrar esto por su cuenta
pausa en el vídeo y piensen en esto en
la parte de abajo
me cuesta un poco de trabajo sostener
esto
pero si llegamos a la parte de abajo de
nuevo imaginen dibujar una recta
tangente aquí como se verá la tangente
de nuevo la inclino para que lo vean un
poco mejor la tangente puede ir en esta
dirección o en esta otra dirección pero
nuevamente como conocemos la dirección
del campo magnético que va en este
sentido la tangente tiene esta dirección
voy a girar la pulsera y noten que la
marca de la flecha indica esta dirección
en la parte de abajo ahora calcularlo de
esta forma está bien si tienen algún
objeto que les ayude como esta pulsera y
esta flecha pero qué pasa si no lo
estuvieran imaginarse esto puede ser
algo difícil al menos lo era para mí así
que les mostraré lo que yo hago cuando
no tengo objetos de apoyo el primer paso
es sostenerlo con la mano derecha son
los mismos pasos y ahora imagino que el
campo magnético se mueve en esta
dirección
ustedes también traten de imaginar esto
el campo magnético se mueve así ahora
sin usar algún objeto voy a usar mi dedo
como
una flecha y lo voy a mover en la
dirección del campo magnético y si
quiero conocer la dirección de un campo
magnético en un punto específico voy a
detener mi dedo en ese punto por ejemplo
si quiero saber la dirección del campo
magnético del lado derecho me detengo
aquí y noten que va hacia abajo y si
queremos conocer la dirección del campo
magnético abajo detengo mi dedo aquí y
vean va hacia la izquierda si quiero
saber el campo magnético del lado
izquierdo va hacia arriba y así
sucesivamente
así es como usamos la regla de la mano
derecha y luego usamos el dedo para
señalar la dirección de la línea del
campo para encontrar la dirección del
campo magnético en cualquier punto
específico resolvamos algunos problemas
tenemos un cable por el que pasa una
corriente eléctrica de oeste a este
encuentra la dirección del campo
magnético en un punto directamente
debajo del cable aquí tenemos que usar
las direcciones norte-sur este
y oeste recuerden que hacia allá es el
norte
este es el sur la derecha es este y la
izquierda es oeste arriba y abajo así
que tenemos un cable por el que pasa una
corriente eléctrica de oeste a este de
oeste a este es esta dirección
este es el cable la corriente va de
oeste a este
necesitamos encontrar la dirección del
campo magnético en un punto por debajo
del cable pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolverlo primero por su cuenta muy
bien vamos a hacerlo primero usamos la
mano derecha para sujetar este conductor
de esta forma en donde el pulgar señala
la dirección de la corriente eléctrica
así que lo sujetamos de esta forma y los
cuatro dedos indican que el campo
magnético tiene esta dirección ahora no
usaremos ningún objeto de apoyo vamos a
usar nuestra imaginación el campo
magnético se mueve de esta forma estoy
usando mi dedo para representar esto y
ya que quiero conocer el campo magnético
por debajo del cable
detenerme debajo del cable ahora en esta
dirección
así que debajo del cable la dirección
del campo magnético es hacia el norte no
es arriba esto es arriba esto es al
norte por lo que la respuesta es al
norte resolvamos un problema más supón
que estás de pie en tu cuarto y
encuentras a un electrón que se mueve
del techo al suelo justo frente a ti
encuentra la dirección del campo
magnético a tu derecha muy bien pensemos
en esto estamos en nuestro cuarto o en
esta habitación y hay un electrón que se
mueve del techo al suelo de esta manera
y queremos encontrar cuál es la
dirección del campo magnético a nuestra
derecha y quizás se pregunten de dónde
salió el electrón recuerden que un
electrón es una partícula cargada y
siempre que se mueve una partícula
cargada va a generar una corriente
eléctrica y sabemos que una corriente
produce un campo magnético es por eso
que hay un campo magnético aquí y
tenemos que encontrar cuál es
de ese campo magnético de nuestro lado
derecho esto es un poquito engañoso
porque el electrón tiene una carga
negativa de nuevo pause en el vídeo y
traten de resolverlo muy bien la parte
engañosa está en que los electrones son
partículas con carga negativa por lo que
si el electrón o la carga negativa se
mueve hacia abajo entonces la dirección
de la corriente va a ser hacia arriba
porque recuerden que la dirección de la
corriente eléctrica es la dirección de
la carga positiva y la dirección opuesta
a la carga negativa y ya que el electrón
se mueve hacia abajo entonces la
dirección de la corriente es hacia
arriba de esta forma esta es la única
parte engañosa
ahora tenemos que encontrar la dirección
del campo magnético aquí si no lo han
hecho antes este es un buen momento para
pausar el vídeo y ver si pueden
resolverlo
muy bien el primer paso es usar la mano
derecha para sujetar este conductor de
manera que el pulgar señale la dirección
de la corriente eléctrica y ahora los
cuatro dedos nos indican la dirección
del campo magnético esto me dice que el
campo magnético se mueve en esta
dirección ahora uso mi dedo para indicar
la dirección de esta forma el campo
magnético se mueve de esta forma y como
queremos encontrar la dirección en el
lado derecho nos detenemos en la derecha
y va a ir en esta dirección esto es al
norte por lo que el campo magnético aquí
tiene dirección al norte que aprendimos
en este vídeo aprendimos cómo usar la
regla de la mano derecha para encontrar
la dirección del campo magnético
básicamente donde tengamos un conductor
de corriente vamos a usar la mano
derecha para sujetarlo de manera que el
pulgar indique la dirección de la
corriente eléctrica y los cuatro dedos
indican cuál es la dirección de este
campo magnético